apparently certain games media websites
are not getting codes for Suicide Squad
kill the Justice League IGN's des and
legary said I gave curse of Osiris a 5.5
out of 10 of bunge still sent us codes
Suicide Squad WB is not sending IGN
review codes after my negative preview
is ridiculous and I'm not even on the
review even the sponsored stream had
characters failed to appear during cut
scenes while CM deleted comments
criticizing the gameplay several other
previews echoed my criticisms not a good
look the game doesn't have a ton of
reviews or or Insight out about it yet
but I want to say this is always a bad
sign if you had faith in a product you
wouldn't be worried about giving review
codes even to outlets that previewed the
game negatively and I will never
understand people who defend this
particular practice like I know you
might hate games media but there's no
real downside to there being more
people's opinions on something outside
of the Publishers advertising or
marketing right like you as a gamer
getting more access to more information
that isn't just paid for marketing seems
like a net positive to me